ils ont choisi touche pas à mon poste
voilà ils avaient le choix entre plein
d'émissions ce sont vraiment des stars
énorme eh bien ils sont avec nous sur le
plateau les tokio hotel sont là
le clan sont avec nous j'adore
il ya bien là la lega bonsoir je vais
faire l'appel bills bills et la bil bil
ça va mon bilan le look what is it vis
looking racistes assez mal efira est
libre tu as coiffure ' je livre la soif
et voir war beautiful afin qu'ils aient
un pénis tels que youtube c'est vrai
qu'on faisait manière non demain je veux
c'est de faire ça pour vous je sais de
ma vie est bon mais merci d'être là en
tout cas vous venez nous voir pour un
nouvel album
c'est le nouvel album de tokio hotel
très très intenses ils sont cinq et de
tokio hotel parce que j'en ai
alors est-ce qu'on vous les gars le
prendre dans le groupe lui à un geek
baie de quiberon la ja
ils ont dit que tu avais une sale gueule
qu'est ce qu'il en est les moyens et un
traducteur pour adultes pour les bourses
intéressantes et je vous avez raison
vous avez bien raison alors vous venez
nous voir pour un nouvel album on va en
parler dans un instant puis je vous
ferai un petit jeu vous allez jouer avec
nous mais pour le moment on regarde
regardez ces nouveaux clips des tokio
hotel ça arrive en france bien sûr et
ich bin foot c'est à dire je suis très
content voilà merci
le traducteur il est là traducteur pour
la personne a décidé de couper les ponts
avec avec moi il ya un traducteur c'est
bon traducteur ringer chante agacé ça il
est là comme ça il vient il s'en va y
reviendrai je sais c'est claude françois
oh
à
je vous le dis je pense vraiment le
nouvel album est très réussi on a bien
fait d'attendre non mais franchement
c'est très très réussie après cinq ans
d'absence vous avez réussi votre retour
et le clip les gars on n'appelle pas les
potes ça veut dire on est tranquille pas
finir cet automne merci beaucoup à vous
inviter au prochain et vous le dis vous
êtes en tournée
voilà vous allez ton tournée vous êtes
actuellement en tournée vous serez
notamment demain au trianon à paris et
jeudi à bruxelles
il faut aller les voir parce que les
tokio hotel mat sur scène c'est
exceptionnel la question j'ai envie de
vous poser égard en coiffure on s'est
calmé la ola à 1 qu'est-ce qu'a eue
avant des tifs tous fous d'été ans
vivait le vivent elles fixent à son
béton maintenant on est encore what is
non mais c'est vrai c'est fini ça ça
s'est fini c'est ce que j ai
photographiés photo pourquoi vous avez
changé de look
iouchtchenko feu looking up changer de
temps en temps j'ai un super costumes
pour demain vous allez voir est convenu
nous voir c'est le traducteur habitudes
il commente le catch fait quoi
l'impatience est un commentateur de
catch se prêterait c'est vrai c'est vrai
j'ai dit il et il est magique et
j'adorais ça et cette coiffure c'est
fini au 26 mai je n'ai pas reconnu ce
soit et c'est vrai que c'est toi je suis
le bo est haute et basse est fini tout
ça toi par leicester vous paraître et
elle a le goût et new look like valérie
bénaïm
c'est bon ça y est c'est vrai c'est
parce que vous avez voulu aller vite il
allait changer de coiffure
ce sont des jumeaux en tout cas demain
merci d'être là vous avez changé de look
mais vous avez gardé votre talent je
voulais vous le dire et c'est vrai que
le nouvel album vraiment est très réussi
pourquoi avoir attendu cinq ans pour
revenir chercher l'inspiration il
fallait que deux reprises on est au
travail est donc qu'il faut pas le petit
pose de migennes ricol a fait deux
nouveaux albums là bas mais m et moi en
tout cas je voudrais vous remercier
d'avoir choisi touche pas à mon poste
que je suis extrêmement honoré vraiment
de vous avoir et en plus moi je suis
assez fan ne vous gérez bien consciente
un peu ensemble le tube d'avant là
j'aime bien mais ce que je peux vraiment
c'est
et je mets des buts mais je trouve elle
en a capella pêche la capella sans
musique
on peut dire oh mais je vais lui parler
yoga tu m'as pas est-ce qu'il peut le
faire on pouvait pas me le faire pour
moi comme ça on à l'aquaplaning musique
est ce que tu peux faire un bon d'accord
d'une chose il faut que tu viennes l'eau
on va chanter un allemand en anglais
dans chaque spectacle
les français aiment en temps
également je vais te l'apprendre 0 juste
pour te dire tu as lot à une saucisse là
allez serviable le gard direct le
hollandais de tu as d'un restaurant fait
de la faible et donc et demain vous
allez chanter donc en anglais en
français en allemand
pourquoi vous avez plein d'albums comme
angle est maintenant finie l'allemand
vous sentez plus en allemand cette fois
ci on n'a pas tout chanté en allemand
allait écrire l'anglais on veut le
garder ça on ne l'est pas de traductions
d'accord parce que vous venez bien sûr
dalmat nous habite et où actuellement
jusqu'à paris super ok on arrive de
marché superbe hôtel on va aller à paris
on connaissait le temps mais j'ai ouvert
d'accord d'accord alors on va faire un
petit jeu tous les deux
c'est la première fois tous les quatre
d'ailleurs tous les 500 points merci
on aimerait vous connaître un petit peu
plus donc on va faire un lequel des
quatre d'accord sur une faillite de bear
s'unissent pour lequel des quatre et le
moins content d'être ici je crois que
c'est lui
ces essais un bond de skyrock c'est lui
non j'adore lequel dès que lequel des
quatre et le plus dragueur en soirée
c'est qui c'est top cet homme c'est top
de quelle des 4 et le plus et le plus
dragueur en soirée on est tous des
blondes mais on a tous nos petites
familles communiqué je suis dit ma terre
comme lui d'autres lui galère beaucoup
plus amène dans son hôtel je parle ce
que je dis en plus ma mère si c'est bon
c'est un qu'elle des quatre regrette le
plus son ancienne coiffure on voit les
photos
celui qui regrette le plus celui qui se
dit j'avais un bon look quand ils se
revoient à la cnps et un nul alors que
je veux mes cheveux et à sa freebox à la
casquette mais je vous en donne offrir
une vous dans votre héroïne voulait une
casquette casquette magnifique aluminium
d'accord une nouvelle casquette si les
deux casquettes pastis 51 les
magnifiques régaler à l'épaule
les temps a parlé tout à l'heure dans
l'équipe lequel des quatre est le plus
radin le plus rationnel c'est trop le
nom leur adresse d'un dilemme moral
donné par jean monnet seger même testé
près de moissac euros après toi sacoche
tous les rend demain tu vas voir je
déraille je les ramènerais sur l'année
serait tellement d'argent
dans ses poches menaçait de débord mais
il est bon mais tu sais moi vous parler
penser enfin moi je voulais vous dire en
tout cas on est très heureux de vous
avoir ce que voulait rester un petit peu
avec nous elle est ce que vous voulez
partir il conte la vérité parce que nous
on est très contents de vous avoir
content d'être là a deux amours
alors il faut savoir qu'au fil des tomes
vous avez été jurée dans la dans la lah
dans d'autres langues sur 100 superstar
donc c'est l'équivalent allemand de la
nouvelle star ça vous a plus à diana
kate
diplômé de ses environs amusant une
saison on l'a rencontré des jeunes les
musiciens mais on l aime faire notre
propre musique
alors on préfère qu'on va répéter
l'expérience
moi aussi je les présente et j'ai pas
répéter ce que vous racontez c'était
juge aussi une enquête chanteur
j'ai gagné la saison 3 ouais faut que tu
viens là c'est de chanter mon seul et si
vous voulez je vous souhaite une chanson
tu me dis ce que tu en penses quoi me
met un rouge ou un bleu l'annoncé de ces
accords et chante je les adore il faut
qu'on s'en satisfait qu'il faut soit
vous êtes des amours dégagé l'impression
d'être des stars mondiales
attention chante une chanson de de kenji
reconnaissait kenji
quatre chanteurs français
merci one last year is to toi à toi ma
belle andalouse aussi belle que
jalousent portugal quand sarah était
plein de que je perds la tête comme ma
belle espagnole
quand tu bouges de taizé paul alors
là
je sais je sais alors c'est vrai alors
les gars si vous avez besoin vous êtes
carte aujourd'hui vous appelez les tokio
hotel si vous voulez je viens dans le
groupe et vous appelez les tokio hôtel
cinq étoiles palace c'est bon on est
seul on fait ça ou pas ils sont au bout
du rouleau la fois pour ça je voudrais
dire vraiment que le nouvel album est
très très réussie vous êtes vraiment des
amours et finalement vous jouez le jeu
voilà vous êtes des stars
internationales il joue le jeu il se
marre avec nous et je voulais vous
remercier
voilà pour votre humilité et franchement
vous êtes désamour si vous voulez rester
avec nous moi ça avec plaisir
voilà en fait là il est il et il est
20h30 et une en allemand sap excursus
plus donc ça fait 20h31 have passed face
et on finit l'émission à 45 et hamouma
ou pas voulais rester
justin ministère ok ok j'ai déjà mon
choix vous angoisser
arrivé
c'est parce que vous restiez veulent
partir des risques allégués vous
accueillir c'est mon fiancé iphone si
ron silver lake et angela merkel it's my
phone chironi les dans l'émission
voulais le voir c'est camille combal
c'est parti